يبدو ان حكايه شهريار والسياف انعكست
لتدور حكايه اليوم عن شهرزاد والساطور بعد
ان سجلت وزاره الداخليه العراقيه حوالين
233 حاله عنف ضد الرجال لهذا العام
السابقين كان تعنيف الرجل طرفه يتداولها
العراقيون فيما بينهم اما اليوم فاصبح
حقيقه مضحكه مبكيه لدى الكثيرين منهم وعلى
الرغم من تصاعد حالات العنف ضد الرجال الا
انهم يصرون على التعامل مع الامر على انه
نكته فالمجتمع هناك اعتاد ان يكون الرجل
هو المعنف للضحيه اما بالنسبه للنساء
فيجددنا ان العنف الذي تسببنا به ما هو
الا رد فعل لافعال كثيره وقعت عليهم
بين عامين 2014 و 2020 سجل العراق اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف حاله عنف ضد الرجال اختلفت
اسبابها واغلب هذه الحالات ان لم تكن
جميعها وقعت بفعل زوجاتهم وتنوع العنف بين
اللفظ والجسدي و بعضه ادى لقتل الرجل او
انتحاره
تزداد حالات العنف ضد الرجال في اقليم
كردستان العراق فهنالك مراكز خاصه لواء
رجال المعنفين وترى الناشطات في مجال حقوق
المراه ان هنالك اسباب متعدده تدفع نساء
للعنف منها الفقره وتضيق المجتمع على
المراه فضلا عن ظاهره تعدد الزوجات كل هذه
الاسباب تدفع لانتشار هذه الظاهره زينب
المشهد صباح العربيه بغداد
هذا الخطا انا الصور انهم التربيه احنا
عاده نحترم والدنيا نحترم اخونا وايضا
احترم الزوج ما يصير انه يتجاوز على الرجل
المفروض نحترمه سبب تعنيف المراه للرجل هو
يعني تغير او اختلاف نوعيه الرجال
المراه تتجاوز على الرجل هذا ليس من
اخلاقنا كالمجتمع شرقي اسلامي
السبب اليوم الرجل ضعف الشخصيه يختار
امراه اقوى من عندها بالشخصيه
لطيفه مشاعر راقيه تصنع الحياه وخلقنا من
انفسكم ازواجا فالربما ظروف نفسيه او
لضغوط حياتيه او لربما اسريه كلها يدفعها
بهذا التنمر وهذا فعل